three year old Baba Kaka almost didn't
survive the boy is still extremely weak
he's currently being cared for by an
acquaintance his mother can't look after
him because she was badly injured during
the Nigerian Army's rescue operation
last week the captors gave their
hostages very little to eat sometimes
not more than a small portion of cool
yeah of course Oh question wooden
equivalent I still think about how Boko
Haram came to our village and kidnapped
us life in their prison was unbearable
the worst was the constant hunger I'll
never forget he ever no not again of the
150 children of this camp more than 40
are suffering from malnutrition after
their ordeal bhavik acha doesn't even
weigh seven kilograms yelling my goddess
thank you baby I'm okay sigelei majalis
the nurses still have some special food
for the underfed children but supplies
are low and there's no sign of the
doctor assigned to the camp he didn't
show up for his shift two nurses and one
midwife that's the entire medical
personnel that's available for the
extremely weakened and traumatized women
and children here in the camp and nobody
knows how it will continue in the next
days and weeks 20 of the most severely
injured children and women were
immediately taken to the hospital in
yola after they were freed including
Bubba Kaka's mother Nana Moussa she was
seriously hurt when a woman in front of
her stepped on a landmine during the
rescue operation no no where do I and I
thank God I survived in the military too
I hope one day I can lead a normal life
again with my family you know some
psychologists have come to visit the
camp their job is to find the most
traumatized victims and offer them
therapy the more they talk about the
world has they've gone through and the
more activities that they they join in
the easier it's going to be even for the
counseling but also we draw you know and
do not want to participate in anything
those are the ones that I'm worried
about baba Kaka's condition worsened in
a matter of hours the nurses rushed him
to hospital but the emergency room was
full and there were no spare beds he was
eventually admitted after much
discussion and placed in the same room
as his mother